depuis quelques temps des sportifs de la
côte basse s'était fixé pour devoir de
vacances dit acclimater le surfing nez
sur les plages d'hawaii un nom
mystérieux mais un sport sans mystère
muni d'une large planche il s'agit de
gagner la haute mer et de la utilisant
le mouvement des vagues de partir à
l'assaut du rivage
c'est ce qu'ont fait ou essayer de faire
à biarritz les concurrents du premier
championnat de france et d'europe 2 sur
film porté par les fortes vagues des
marées d'équinoxe maintenant regarde
non
sans doute penserez vous à présent que
le surfing est un sport passionnant
comme l'ont prouvé pour la première fois
en france les champions de biarritz
[Musique]
un pont sur la manche
voilà bien la nouvelle sensationnelle de
ses vacances encore convient-il de ne
pas s'affoler et de savoirs attend du
cap blanc nez on ne peut encore que
sauter dans la mer
le projet ne saurait au mieux être
réalisé qu'en 67
quoi qu'il en soit le pont tel qu'il est
conçu 33km admettra train et voiture
six mille à l'heure précise t-on à 70
mètres au dessus des flots il sera de
plain-pied si l'on peut dire avec la
falaise du cap blanc nez où sera édifié
une vaste autogare et bâtiments avec
magasins restaurants postes d'essence de
tout radar
de moderne d'installation de douane et
de ph
et c'est peut-être ainsi qu à sangatte
le non moins fameux projet de tunnel
sous la manche en restera au point où il
en est toujours un trou moore et bien
sûr les signes ne sont pas tous aussi à
danser mais ceci en angleterre ont
résolu au mieux le problème de leur
départ
comme dans la pension la mieux organisée
il suffit de sonner pour être servi
monsieur signe s'est fort bien les
usages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est autre chose chez ces canards d'une
ferme du lac baïkal
on ne commande pas son déjeuner mais on
obéit à la cloche du réfectoire
[Applaudissements]
et deux fois par jour à la peine
règlementaire 21000 canard oui pas moins
se précipiteront de la plage vers les
mangeoires intelligence de l'estomac
aucun son de cloche ne saurait encore
amener les cas plan sur les plages de
terre-neuve à quoi bon d'ailleurs
puisqu'ils viennent d'eux mêmes si
abandonnés chaque été par bancs entiers
c'est l'époque traditionnelle de la
pêche miraculeuse obligatoire et les
pêcheurs s'en donnent à coeur joie
on a eu pas quand ces charmants poisson
atteint d'un mal étrange rien là que de
très naturel puisqu'il s'agit simplement
de la migration annuelle qui amènent des
capelans déposer leurs oeufs dans les ca
ovo kaplan du reste ils iront finir par
tous nos entier comme appât pour la
pêche à la morue et dire qu'ils y
mettent tant de bonne volonté
les vacances sont le temps béni des
rencontres combien de personnages il
habituel rencontré par hasard
voici quelques-uns à turckheim en alsace
le veilleur de nuit des livres d'imagés
toujours vivant chaque nuit depuis 15
140 date à laquelle les registres de
turckheim commence à en faire mention
le veilleur de nuit classique avec
l'interné hallebardes fait quatre fois
le tour du village
[Applaudissements]
est ce le dernier représentant de cette
noble corporation
on peut le croire à saint germain jude
sur les dernières pentes du jura le
garde champêtre fait ses tournées à
cheval il va toi que chacun de ses
administrés connaît aussi bien la
monture que le fonctionnaire et même les
attentions particulières vont plutôt
brave animal
voici quinze ans que monsieur bien qui
exerce ses fonctions voici quinze ans qu
il les exerce à cheval il est sans doute
en france le sol dans son cas maintenant
si l'on cherche les raisons de cette
anomalie pittoresque on ne trouve pas de
réponse ou une salle mais convaincante
ancien gendarme à cheval le garde
champêtre a voulu rester cavaliers
[Musique]
a jouy le châtel le pharmacien est une
pharmacienne rien jusque là que de très
banal mais cette pharmacienne aime la
musique banal encore et son instrument
et le tambour
c'est exceptionnel
non
une pharmacienne chef depuis on avait
quand même jamais vu ça
oh
ds d'autrefois et d'aujourd'hui celle de
la saison prochaine verront la hauteur
des jupes diminuer la taille remonter la
ceinture réapparaît voici en tailleur ou
basques courte en manteau l'insee base
et les petites soeurs de celles qui
furent la vénus d'arles et la diane de
gabia car nous sommes à la fois chez
praxitèle et chez christian dior réunie
ce soir au musée du louvre pour cet
hiver
les manteaux buste menu s'évase
résolument ancône nantes étroites et col
miniature garniture de fourrures sont
les traits dominants de cette ligne à la
fois très simple et sophistiquée
[Musique]
pour le cocktail c'était l'heure du
nectar et de l'emploi zee dans le monde
des dieux grecs la ligne sinueuse home
il plisse essai transformé mais garde
tout le charme de sa féminité
[Musique]
voici les robes et les tailleurs 6
heures minuit décolleté au ras du cou et
la jupe sert les hanches pour s'évaser
rouge nous
pour les grands soirs et les galas de
l'olympe de ligne le fourreau légèrement
évasé à bust long et la robe large et
ondoyant mais la fantaisie et l'audace
gardent leurs droits sous l'oeil de zeus
[Applaudissements]
les sont coulés l'émeute dans leur magie
qui unit sans brutalité le plus beau
passer au charme du présent et qui
rapproche si facilement les femmes de
tous les temps
la mode c'est l'heure des ds
[Musique]